what did that teach you that whole
process creating something having it
struggling with it and eventually having
to let it go I think it taught me that
you know you can be passionate you can
be bullheaded single-minded you know I'm
an Aries and I you know will not will
not ever quit I think you realize that
if you have an idea and you're
passionate about it it's not necessarily
the idea it's the execution so if you've
gone down a road and you've given it
everything you can and then for some
reason or another it's just not quite
working it does help to stop down
reevaluate and change your strategy you
don't have to change your goal but the
strategy is what needs to be examined
and that's what I did when I had to shut
down that company and it's similar to
when I stopped acting instead of
directing my goal remained relatively
the same you know to be able to create
to be able to you know have TV shows and
films and you know theatre that I that I
directed produced was involved with my
strategy has never changed I mean my my
goal has never changed but the
strategies I reevaluate you know if
things if you like thrown everything you
could into it it may be time to
reevaluate do you remember that day that
you said okay I think it's time this
isn't it for me I'm so young and vital
but I I need to do something well it I
mean it is it's a little personal but it
coincided with a divorce as well okay um
sorry talking about I give up it sounds
like though but you came to a process in
your mind that and then we can you know
why are we can start again so we don't
have to I mean I don't mind I it's you
know it's your typical I've heard of
many relationships have been casualties
of this business um it's uh but you
still wanted to be in the business you
just wanted to go about in a different
way yes like okay so do you remember the
day you said okay I think I need to
close the theater business I i think i
need closes theater yeah i mean it you
know
it was where I was rolling debt from one
show into the next and it just got to
the point where the numbers weren't
going to add out no matter what I did it
wouldn't have been it wouldn't have an
ethical for me he going sure because I
imagine it's similar to a film mm-hmm
and people still try to like put so much
into one project and it's time to maybe
let that project go and move on to
something new yeah so what I was more
going for and I'm sorry if I'm getting
too personal is is just a mental process
and and that moment inside where you
said okay this is going to be to the
detriment of me my finance whatever and
how you processed saying it's time to to
say goodbye and yeah I how did you let
people know i think i think it was when
you realize like i had done everything I
could do and it had turned out the way I
wanted it to turn out and then but I
didn't have the results I didn't have
the audience I didn't have the financial
success and and I think you're like well
this is exactly what I envisioned and it
didn't work so I've got to change the
process it was really that simple for me
and honestly working in LA and doing
theatre it was a little counterintuitive
if you think about it I'd came out here
to be in film and television and I ended
up doing what I was most comfortable
with which was theater trying to make
the inner work in this town is difficult
just ask the people who run the Mark
Taper you know in the Dorothy Chandler
um and if that was Italy I was like well
I better you know I better join in and
start doing the film and television in
the film television capital of the world
right and do you look back on it and
realized that the closing of that
theater and and the
hang on was a good do you feel like you
should have done it earlier but do you
feel yeah with your own progress in it
oh absolutely I you know I still have
the posters of the of the plays that I
did it you know on my wall and and it
definitely gave me you know i ended up
directing like 50 productions over the
over the course of a couple years and it
definitely it was it was training you
know i always say you can't go back on
your life and like take a slice of it
out and say well I'd be happy where I am
now except for that one piece which I'm
going to take out if everything you do
is it part of what makes you who you are
and doing those shows and just working
over and over it's like exercising or
working out or you know keeping that
fresh in your mind theatre is so
wonderful because you don't cut between
scenes and you get to see the story from
beginning to end every night and there's
a lot of life in that and film and
television is very different because we
chopped it all up and you're shooting
out of sequence and you know sometimes
you go back month later to finish scenes
so you never really get that sense of
completion so I definitely look back on
my theater background and experience as
as a huge advantage because then once I
took that is it's it's very pure in in
the art and the interpretation of the
material and you take that artistic just
purity and you mix it in with the
technical that film and television is
because it is massively technical you
have to you know that theatre through
line is a strength for me as a director
now because i had that pure artistic
foundation and now I've got the artistic
I mean I've got the technical expertise
and now it's a natural combination
that's why Senate oves is so exciting to
do is that it's the natural culmination
of what I've been working on my whole
life
you